it's kind of
blurry that's
better question what kind of bear is
best that's a ridiculous question false
black bear well that's debatable there
are basically two schools of thought
fact bears eat beats oh Bears beats
Battlestar Galactica bears do not what
is going on what are you doing last week
I was in a drugstore and I saw these
glasses uh
$4 and it only cost me $7 to recreate
the rest of the Ensemble and that's a
grand total
of $11
you know what imitation is the most
sincere form of flattery so I thank
you identity theft is not a joke Jim
millions of families suffer every
year Michael oh that's funny Michael for
5 years I've held my instincts in check
because I wanted to be made
manager maybe it's time for me to just
let that thought
go it's kind of painful but it's also
freeing in a way now it's all about my
instincts hey Dwight
Stanley one way or another you are going
to come with me to make this sale pass
can you just let me out of here before
whatever comes next don't worry it's
just a bull tranquilizer nothing to be
alarmed about it's just a man pointing a
bull tranquilizer at a coworker DWI you
do not learn do you for a threat to be
credible you have
holy no you didn't sick of you and
your it's all right Andy approved it man
he's really in twinkle town now is he
going to be okay I mean weren't those
darts intended for an animal like two to
three times larger than him okay this
dosage was meant for a very small ball
and Stanley's got way more body fat than
they do you gave him three shots sh
got about 45 minutes to get him to the
client before he comes too grab his
feet let's go all right move it one two
three like a manate ready let's go again
come on we can do this one two
three oh God no wonder my elevator
cables are under such strain we got to
get a wheelbarrow or something
yes uh yeah I just got my replacement
credit
card do you want the number oh it's uh
3313 the security code is
927 okay great thank you very much
bye so Dwight did take the
bait he used my credit card numbers to
send a $200 bouquet of
flowers to my
wife from
[Laughter]
me
boom what is this what happened here I
don't know oh this does not look good
did anyone see what happened happed
around my desk area this morning D I
really think someone's probably just
playing a prank on you so just go right
through it a prank huh this is official
police line tape okay it's not a prank
probably is damn it people someone must
have seen
something oh you people are useless
Jesus Thunder Mifflin this is Pam hold
please Dwight it's the sheriff he said
that it's really important it's
regarding your desk I'll transfer oh no
no don't I
[Music]
can't just cut through it man it's no
big deal this is why I am a volunteer
Sheriff's deputy and you are not that is
not
why wow man he really wants to get in
touch with you maybe it's a murder no
there's no blood maybe poison possibly
my
God no J
no Sheriff this is volunteer sheriff's
deputy Dwight shrew
press the pound
key what's your 20's office this is
Kevin Malone is David there no he's on
his weekly staff being can I take a
message tell him I'm mad at Jim cuz he's
asking us to give money to Pam this is
Stanley Hudson Jim Halbert is a menace
it's Toby
Fenderson listen things are getting
really bad down here
last week I gave a fire safety
talk and nobody paid any
attention it's my own fault for using
PowerPoint PowerPoint is boring people
learn in lots of different ways but
experience is the best
teacher
today smoking is going to save
lives does anyone smell anything smokey
did you bring your jerky
again oh my God uh oh my
God fire oh fire oh my goodness what's
the procedure what do we do people are
dead how did that happen it's out in the
hall no we don't know that the smoke
could be coming through an air duct oh
my God okay it's happening everybody
stay calm what's the procedure everyone
what's the
procedure calm down no no Michael no
touch the handle if it's hot there could
be a fire in the
hallway what does warm mean oh my gosh
not a viable option what next the other
door oh here's a door check that one out
how's the handle it's warm okay go to
the back door another option another
jeez okay settle down everyone I forgot
my leave it woman get out of the way go
go go no things can be replaced Phyllis
people human lives however
can a my hand that's hot this one's hot
too okay we're trapped everyone for
himself let's go let's go get out of my
way okay
okay please have you ever seen a burn
victim okay procedure procedure
excellent options where do we go folks
use a what to cover the mouth a what a
rag a damp rag perhaps let's remember
those procedures what are the options
okay that's the wrong way we've already
tried that remember your exit points
exit points people what's next huh stay
alive I'm getting help pull me up you're
too heavy I only weigh 82 lbs sa
Bandit how about 911 anyone
911 what do we do use this surge of fear
and adrenaline to sharpen your decision
making okay I am not dying here come
on what is that the fire shooting at us
what the name is going
[Music]
on
[Applause]
oh
attention employees of Thunder Mifflin
this has been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation what fire not real
this was merely a training
exercise so what have we
learned oh come on it's not real Stanley
don't have
no no no no no you will not die Stanley
Stanley you will not die Stanley Stanley
Barack is President you are black sley
I'm going to give him mouth to mouth no
no no don't give him mouth to mouth for
this you going to swallow his T open
your mouth SW don't swallow
it I'm fine leave me
Al
[Music]
I have no feeling in my fingers are
penis but I think it was worth
it um I was laying on the ground
defenseless and uh he just kept throwing
him into till he exhausted himself and
uh then how about icing it LOL D
White